i love this guy i mean and he was
you know uh there's a lot of people that
are like [__] drug dealers or
whatever like uh my friend eddie called
me last week and he watched the
pablo escobar uh thing and he was like
that guy was brilliant
he was a [__] drug dealer he was a
genius you know there's a lot of people
just because they're criminals or
whatever doesn't mean they're
intelligent they're not intelligent
these guys could run a fortune 500 ceo
better than these [__] morons with
their [__] master's degree
and all this [__] they do it from
[__] scratch
and this was one of these guys juan was
one of these guys that even though he
was kind of [__] up
good looking guy always dressed nice the
whole thing
he was a businessman so the first thing
he did was he bought a
a flower shop you know when he got out
of parole he bought a flower shop on
57th and hudson in new jersey
and again in the summers we think how to
work with him me i had to go over there
get the roses we'd de-stem [__] roses
at four in the morning
and then he'd sell them at the flower
shop but then he came with a better idea
he goes dog what if we get dozens of
roses
and sell them on the street corners in
new york not to mention i could take
numbers
people could drop by my other bookies
and drop off the action to me
and when i drive back into jersey i got
everything done for the day this
[__] 74 started selling roses
on all the streets in new york he had a
couple [__] cuban guys myself we're
out there selling roses taking numbers
it was beautiful i mean that's the kind
of system that's the mind this guy had
and with that money he bought a butcher
shop and the butcher shop was successful
also guess who had to work the butcher
shot i got a bunch of [__] cuts on my
hand from cutting me
not even knowing that's what he did and
the whole time he had the numbers
operation but he had the butcher shot
he was really trying to go legit and the
other thing was he was really trying to
be my dad he had a daughter from a
previous marriage and they [__] up
with the jail time this guy was really
trying to be my dad he was involved he
was more involved than my mom
my mom was a woman that should have
really really been a man
she ran that [__] bar by herself my
mom would [__]
open it close it she was the doorman the
bartender
you know that was my mom's style when
you're a [__] immigrant you come here
in the 50s and you got nothing
you work 92 [__] hours a day that's
what you do and that's what she did even
though they took the numbers and they
sold heroin they did a bunch of [__]
but they still [__] worked you know
that was the main thing
they were trying to go legit my step-dad
more than my mom
my mom had the bar and she didn't give a
[__] she had money
and she kept [__] was happening at the
bar it was 74 75 there were traces of
cocaine
starting to come up and once cocaine
started come up that really spooked the
[__] out of juan
juan didn't like drugs by no means
reefer if he smelled reefer he would
have a [__] heart attack
he would have a look at these [__]
americans getting weak wait till the
russians come over and [__] them in the
ass that's what he would say
that was his claim to fame he said
russians give these [__] weed
so when they come over in 30 years all
these kids will be sucking their dicks
that's what he that's
that was his that was his [__]
mentality and you really gotta add it to
him he's [__] right sometimes he's
like
look at this [__] [__] with boy you
know he was one of those guys
so he hated that [__] bar and here he
is
trying to go legit with all this [__]
and he at night i would listen to him my
mom talking
and he would tell my mom dog stop with
that bar sell the bar there's going to
be problems
i don't have to be a genius to tell you
there's going to be problems that white
powder is a [__]
and my mom did blow my mom always did
blow even the [__] when i was a kid i
knew they would always scratch her nose
and
she would have little rings and i'd say
mom wipe your [__] nose all right
you're embarrassing me where it's cool
you know whatever the [__] so
it was [__] up that he lived in this
house
that he was against everything but he
loved my mother so much i had grown up
together
and he loved me you know i kept him
grounded he taught me all these things
like when we go to
work in the mornings he would never just
pull up at work he'd go there half hour
early and drive around and make sure
there was no cops around
or no unusual cars then he parked his
car and i mean he was he had a system
for everything he was very intelligent
very precise
you know he kept his mouth shut
everything about him was
i learned i learned so much from this at
this time
and one night i went to karate right
i was a [__] nerd guys i was a
[__] nerd and once bruce lee came out
i became karate man i used to have the
sandals
with the kung fu outfit and i bow in the
mornings and
i'd only rise for breakfast they were
like what the [__] is going on with
these
kids you know so they didn't know but i
was really into it i behaved myself at
that time i was a good kid
my life was school and karate and i
wanted to be i had the new trucks
you know now you [__] got
iphones when i was a kid we had new
trucks [__]
everybody walked around with black and
blues on their elbows and a lump on
their head
from practicing everybody walked a
little different what's wrong dog
i hit my head with a new chuck last week
he
all that [__] so i used to go to this
cuban judo school on 7th street
and i knew that he would go down there
on wednesday nights and play baccarat
they would play cards
and one night i went to judo and i'm
coming out i see four
cops with their uniforms talking and the
detective
like they're talking about something and
i made a mental note and i got on the
bus
and i went back home and i was get home
he's getting dressed like where you
going he goes i'm going to play cards
and i
go dog you should stay home tonight and
he goes why and i go
nothing he thought i was like because i
would always say to him stay home you
know on wednesdays let's watch get
christy love
there was a show we both like we got ice
cream and this night he goes nah i gotta
go play cards i gotta get my money back
from last week
and i go dog don't go down there i seen
cops down there
and he goes ah you're just paranoid so
you got in this car he left about 20
minutes later he comes back with like
[__] ham and cheese and he goes
i thought about what you said i'm gonna
stay home with you the next morning
he wakes me up he goes look at the paper
there was a [__] raid down there
thank you he goes finally i taught you
something you got eyes
he goes you got [__] street eyes now
i'm proud of you you know because i'm
proud of you you saved my life last
night
let's go do something and he was just he
you know he didn't want me to be a
criminal guys he always
helped me with homework he always stayed
i mean
you know he was always into that and you
know what there comes a point in your
life when you're a boy
uh a young man like 11 or 12 that
our fathers become ball busters you know
dog what why is the light on in here
what are you related to con
edison turn the [__] lights off oh
what's this can of soda
were we related to the soda people you
got three cans here you opened three
[__] cans you didn't finish them
drink your [__] soda hey what your
underwear is on the floor pick it up
[__]
you got a [__] maid here guys these
are things that are right he's [__]
right
but when we're 11 [__] you mama do it
why should i [__] do it i ain't doing
no [__] dishes and he would always go
someday i'm gonna be gone and your
mother's gonna be gone
you have to [__] wash those dishes
[__] that you guys ain't dying
you're a bad [__] you just shot
a guy in 148 last week
so it was just [__] amazing he would
stay on me you know